[Music]
we're steps one of the most anticipated
movies this holiday season The Hobbit
the ads make it look like a really fun
film but there's one problem with this
movie let me tell you there's so many
characters joining Bilbo Baggins on his
journey I think audiences are gonna have
a hard time keeping track of all the
different people coming in I know I did
it was it sure take a look
Bilbo Baggins I'm looking for someone to
share in an adventure I can't just go
running off into the blue I am a Baggins
right of Bag End Bilbo allow me to
introduce fili Kili or in glowing Dwalin
Balin bifur Bofur Bombur Dori nori Ori
smooth fingers it will be an extremely
tall dwarf like us the much too young
father mangas the product placement
dwarf Fancy Pants bagel and albino
spider-man
[Applause]
Skyfall still doing very well at the box
office and it is full of action
unfortunately it's also full of mistakes
and if you're a long time James Bond fan
like myself I've seen everyone some of
these mistakes are unforgivable like
this one you made such a bold entrance
until they talk drama hope it isn't over
complicate the plot twists mr. Bing Joe
chomping
[Applause]
[Music]
that took me right out of the movie yeah
he must have been going Undercovers I
don't know yeah Anna Karenina is also
playing right now it's a beautiful
tragic story based on a classic Russian
novel by Leo Tolstoy but I think the
producers of the film tried way too hard
to make the movie appeal to a young
modern audience and they shouldn't have
done that we can be together
how can we annex a token and everything
do you think my husband will make you a
present of me leave it leave him and be
your mistress yes run away I would never
see my son again
[Applause]
I'll never forgive myself
[Music]
this is my hands
[Applause]
[Music]
I was wrong it was an improvement I'm
gonna go see that now I'm gonna see that
boring old Russian butt at work break
yeah
killing them softly with Brad Pitt now I
think Brad's a great actor I'd clone
Brad cuz we're friends it's plausible
anyway I think he's terrific but
unfortunately this movie features some
sloppy filmmaking there are outdoor
scenes were frankly they could have used
a little more crowd control you ever
killed anyone you can get touchy feely
touchy feely emotional not funny love us
love your app for Chanel number five
it's not a journey every journey ends
but we go on the world of cars don't
wreck her with that my luck my fate my
fortune Chanel number five let's see
what
[Applause]
Lincoln Steven Spielberg's a great
director and he proves it again with
this film one brilliant touch is the way
that Spielberg foreshadows Lincoln's
assassination yeah it was I just thought
was great I think was very effective
that's a rule of mathematical reasoning
it's true because it was has done the
only reason that I'll throw things in
spit on a soap opera
[Applause]